of space needs and one of our challenges
is how to keep this growing collection
here and just share it with the public
and you've been watching a recent tour
that book tv took of the folger library
here in washington dc now today marks
the 400th anniversary of the death of
william shakespeare and starting in just
a minute the folger library hosts a
program called the wonder of will it's
filled with performances and remarks
from actors community leaders
politicians artists and scholars this
will be live on book tv
and following that program it's your
opportunity to ask questions or make
comments about william shakespeare
we'll be joined by shakespeare scholar
ellen mckay and folger library director
michael whitmore
and now live coverage from the folger
shakespeare library
[Music]
hello and welcome to the wonder of will
live
i'm michael whitmore director of the
folger shakespeare library and today you
are joining us on a very special day
we're broadcasting here from the
historic pastor reading room for the
past where for the past 80 years
scholars from around the globe have come
to use the largest shakespeare
collection in the world
i'd like to extend a warm welcome today
to all of you who are joining us on
c-span 2 those of you who are joining us
on the live feed
our thanks to book spam book tv and
c-span 2 for making it possible for
shakespeare fans everywhere to enjoy
this special day with us
shakespeare's influence extends beyond
the written word which so your arrival
today was accompanied by music from the
folger consort the folger consort is our
in-house early music ensemble if you're
interested in their music you can find
it on itunes and while you're there have
a look at the wonder of will room that
has been created by itunes apple
partnered with the folger so that we
could collect shakespeare materials for
everyone who wants to celebrate all year
today we're here to celebrate the legacy
of the world's greatest storyteller
and what better way to do that to pay
tribute than with stories
people are celebrating shakespeare all
over the globe today and i am willing to
bet that every one of them has a story
to tell about how they got to know this
amazing writer
400 years ago to this very day
april 23rd
1616
william shakespeare died
the world is much larger and much more
connected today than it was in 1616 and
a lot has happened
but
we are still talking to shakespeare and
for many it feels like he is still in
the room
in fact if you look around this room
where we are today he still is in the
room
how is it that we still have more to say
about this writer and why is it that
when we talk about our own lives we
often seem to be having a conversation
with him
one reason might be because shakespeare
is unavoidable
he is the most produced playwright in
north america
over 90 percent of american school
children encounter shakespeare's works
or his plays not to mention half of the
secondary students on the planet
there are more
shakespeare films made in bollywood
than there are in the united states and
the uk
combined
in terms of filmmaking
there are more the the characters and
the phrases from shakespeare's writings
now appear in dystopian novels disney
cartoons broadway musicals hip-hop and
if you do a google search today you'll
find shakespeare on the banner
four centuries after his death people
from the around the world are still
having a conversation with this glover's
son from warwickshire
with shakespeare lightning seemed to
strike many times in one place
he brought so many gifts to his job as a
writer and a man of the theater whether
it was his canniness about human
emotions or his dazzling use of language
or that unerring ability to find the
human pulse in just about every
situation
it's important that all of these gifts
get expressed in stories because it's in
stories that we learn to pass into the
lives and experiences of others
shakespeare's stories and plays teach us
to empathize with those who are unlike
us and even more important they teach us
about the communities that we might
someday become
for better or for worse
think about the familiar stories that we
find in shakespeare's plays
young love or the beginning of love in
romeo and juliet
or in much ado about nothing
sibling rivalry and as you like it
the loss of family in hamlet
forgiveness
in the winter's tale
self-destruction
in macbeth
standing up for what you believe in
in king lear
or the experience of being treated as an
outsider or another as an othello or the
merchant of venice
shakespeare speaks to us in 2016 because
we still struggle
with politics war
love
and family
and in the end this will always be a
struggle to understand ourselves and
each other
markets and social media will only teach
us so much about what drives us
to learn more we need the humanities and
the arts that inspire them
what better way to celebrate the 400th
anniversary of shakespeare's death than
by bringing together people who can talk
about the moment that they discovered
this amazing writer
and now it's time to hear their stories
in early 2009
president obama appointed our first
presenter as the associate director of
the white house office of public
engagement
however you might know him better as
gogol from the film adaptation of jhumpa
lahiri's the namesake
dr lawrence kutner on house or just
maybe you know him as kumar
what you might not know is that he
shared a very special connection to
shakespeare
from literally the first day he was born
please join me in welcoming cal pen
[Music]
thank you
if there's something everyone knows
about actors we are impulsive and
irrational i'm sure psychologists have a
term for this but the most common
phraseology is actors actors are crazy
and as every report card that i've ever
had like to point out to my poor parents
we are quick to speak before we think
for the most part
i knew i wanted to be an actor because i
loved the power of storytelling from a
very young age in 7th and 8th grades i
used to create characters in my bedroom
and loved entering worlds that i never
could in real life but shakespeare i
mean come on despite my grandfather's
love of shakespeare and an annoying
english teacher or two whenever i'd
glance at the prose i would think
shakespeare i mean come on it's not even
english shakespeare is just overblown
and old and i remember thinking to
myself no one actually talks like that
but then ninth grade came around and
three things happened okay number one i
noticed in small font on the inside
front cover of my english class copy of
selected works of william shakespeare
that william shakespeare was born on the
23rd of april which also happens to be
my birthday i noticed that we share a
birthday and a message was sent to the
crazy part of my over dramatic aspiring
actor mind that this was a sign oh this
was a sign that not only was i going to
be an actor but i was going to be a
working actor and do you know why
because i shared a birthday with this
shakespeare fellow whoever he was he was
respected and relevant and people were
still doing his plays all this time
later number two and please remember i
was only 14 but when we read romeo and
juliet we were allowed to watch in the
classroom
you all know where this is going
the franco zefferelli film adaptation
with which featured what nudity
how is this possible i remember thinking
to myself who is this shakespeare who
has allowed the teacher to show us
nudity that is totally against the rules
no matter that zephyrelli was an
incredibly talented director the fact
that this shakespeare guy got away with
letting ninth graders see someone's
bathing suit area in english class and
was born on my birthday meant that
unconditionally i was going to be an
actor and i was going to read
shakespeare number three
and around this time frankly unrelated
to parts one and two of the story i
actually did read and started to
understand and then fell in love with
shakespeare i started to understand the
beauty of his words the symbolism and
universality i mean i grew up in new
jersey in the early and mid 90s and this
capulet montague beef is about the same
as what we'd see on the local news
except new jersey local news talked
about mob families so you know you
replace verona with hoboken and you've
got yourself the opener to a mafia movie
two households both alike in dignity and
fair hoboken where we lay our scene i
mean even the prologue is rich so
shakespeare in many ways taught me my
first lessons in making exceptions to
rules and i started to read more plays
and some sonnets and understand more and
by the time that i enrolled in ucla as a
theater major i was totally in love with
shakespeare in college i got a call from
mtv news we are holding an advanced
screening of the bas lerman version of
romeo and juliet and looking for a few
drama students to watch the film and
then be interviewed with leonardo
dicaprio and claire danes for a tv
special you up for that yes of course
and i loved the movie we watched it and
it was so contemporary and heated and
sexy and violent and funny and it
excited me even more at the endless
possibility of storytelling because you
didn't have to be american or english or
white or rich to understand or interpret
any of this the mtv interview began they
had their cameras rolling and i opened
up about my feelings i told them how in
eighth grade i used to feel like the
words of shakespeare weren't
decipherable i recall to them how i once
thought to myself i mean it's not even
english but in 10th grade i had come to
understand and respect and revere
shakespeare and yes i loved this movie
and i love shakespeare the mtv special
aired i gathered around with friends in
my dorm and my segment gets closer and i
see my face and the interviewer comes on
we are asking aspiring actors what they
think of shakespeare cowpen how do you
feel about shakespeare close up shot on
me i look so excited i am going to be so
eloquent this is going to be my big
break cal how do you feel about
shakespeare cut to my face
i mean it's not even english and then
the camera cuts to someone else
shakespeare taught me my first lesson in
editing
several more years go by i am still a
struggling actor dissatisfied with
typecasting and hollywood's systemic
refusal to cast colorblind gender-blind
roles and i hear a woman speak on a
panel sponsored by the screen actors
guild she was then the only woman of
color on a major network tv show and she
said i decided long ago that since
hollywood has reasons for not casting me
i was going to make it that much harder
for them to deny that my race and gender
had something to do with it i was going
to be classically trained shakespeare
through this actor taught me the
importance of classical training if not
to break through barriers at least to
make the gatekeepers as uncomfortable as
possible if they weren't going to let
you in
and now here we are
i have been a working actor knock on
wood i have the honor of working in
public service
and i'm speaking at the 400th birthday
of william shakespeare on my 30th
birthday
and i look back and i appreciate the
coincidences so there's this one little
remaining matter of how it all ends
and when shakespeare actually died i did
notice back in ninth grade that he was
born on my birthday or rather i was born
on his but i i never processed the idea
of what it meant that shakespeare also
died on his birthday we actors are
impulsive and irrational we fear and
revere things that aren't there and if
the fact that sharing a birth date with
shakespeare meant i was going to be an
actor surely i can't be selective in
ignoring the fact that it must also mean
that i'm going to die on the 23rd of
april
so in the meantime if i get through
today i'll continue to vouch
for the ability that he has for the
universality of love conflict sorrow and
joy for another 400 years and if not
if i lose a scruple of this sport let me
be boiled to death with melancholy thank
you
oh not today cal pem
happy birthday we're off to a great
start
our next presenter turned an early love
of music into a career that has in turn
empowered people from across the country
to transform their innate curiosity
about the arts into full-fledged
artistic careers and a lifelong pursuit
of creativity as the eleventh chairman
of the nea
jane chu has awarded nearly 220 million
dollars in agency grants please join me
in welcoming
jane chu
[Applause]
[Music]
who's there
those are the first two words in
shakespeare's the tragedy of hamlet the
prince of denmark it's also the
essential question that great literature
asks of us who's there
in ourselves and in our communities and
in the world at large the question of
who's there has continued to resonate
across the ages from when hamlet was
originally published in 1603 to today
when i read hamlet i was in high school
and i was slightly younger than the
hamlet character but like a lot of
adolescents i grappled with answering
the question of who's there for myself
and what really hit home to me reading
hamlet was that i could identify with
how his process of coming to terms with
his own grief at the premature loss of
his father mirrored the loss of my own
father at the age of nine
now there were a few things that were
different from hamlet for example i was
fortunate in that unlike hamlet my
father was not murdered by my uncle
so there wasn't any quest for revenge or
anything like that but the more
essential aspect of facing great loss at
a young age really did hit home with me
hamlet first confronts a world that
tells him to move on to get over it even
hamlet's own mother tells him to cast
thy knighted color off do not forever
with thy veiled lids seek for thy noble
father in the dust thou knowest his
common all that lives must die
passing through nature to eternity
a lot of the conversation in my high
school classroom was around how
difficult it was for hamlet to make a
decision
but for me personally the play was
really about how grief if it's not
properly processed in its own time can
lead to greater challenges hamlet is not
decisive indecisive he's not depressed
he is grieving
so i always felt like hamlet had been
placed in a profoundly unfair position
here he is a young man at the age of
barely being a man and the problems that
he has been handed
by taking the responsibility of fixing
those problems created by the grown-ups
around him so i kept thinking if only
the court had just let hamlet take the
time he needed to feel bad about his
father then maybe the plane wouldn't
have ended in such a tragic ending
but when my father died when i was nine
i found a lot of solace in music playing
the piano through the lessons that i was
taking and pretty soon i started to
realize that so many art forms give us
powerful ways to express ourselves
ways that transcend the use of linear
everyday conversation
and i found a lot of comfort in hamlet
because i recognized that i was not
alone because if shakespeare had written
about the process of confronting one's
own grief more than 400 years ago then i
was not the only person to ever have
these feelings and that i surely would
also be okay
shakespeare lets hamlet pass forward the
lesson about the importance of grief
through his dying words to his best
friend horatio and those words help us
understand the power of taking the time
to say goodbye to our loved ones and
keeping their stories alive in our
hearts
if thou didst ever hold me in my heart
absent thee from felicity a while and in
this harsh world draw thy breath in pain
to tell my story
thank you
thank you chairman chu
[Applause]
shakespeare's influence is not limited
to the arts and the humanities
to see this in action you need to look
no further than outer space
with uranus moons named cordelia puck
and ophelia our next guest is going to
feel just right at home here at the
folger
as nasa's chief scientist dr ellen
stofan studies the geology of venus mars
saturn's moon titan and the earth
please join me in welcoming dr ellen
stofan
[Music]
sweet moon william shakespeare wrote in
a midsummer's night dream i thank thee
for thy sunny beams i thank thee moon
for shining now so bright
i wonder if shakespeare ever envisioned
worlds with many moons such as the 27
moons of uranus which bear the names of
shakespeare's characters
each of these moons is its own little
world from the messy fractures of
miranda pulled and twisted by uranus to
the dark and ancient cratered surface of
umbriel but it is right and good to pay
homage to shakespeare with these points
of light in the night sky
to a man who has brought so much light
to so many people
as he has encapsulated the very nature
of what it means to be human
in 2011 i sat in the theater royal in
haymarket london
having the amazing experience of
watching ralph fines play prospero in
the tempest the program noted that the
play was first
performed
for james the first in london
in 1611
and the thought of that actually made me
stop paying attention to the play for a
few minutes
for 400 years
in that very city in theaters
people like me
or maybe slightly more royal
had sat in theaters
hearing those same words laughing at
those same lines
what's past is prologue
we are such stuff as dreams are made of
and so on
i found as much relevance to my life and
my modern era
in his words
as the people that watched it with james
the first probably found to theirs
the ability to bring life into art
and to make it last for centuries
that is the gift of shakespeare
i find in the timeless appeal and revel
relevance of shakespeare
the same thing that i actually love
about geology
about the study of our earth our solar
system our universe
for billions of years
stars planets galaxies are born they
live
they die
we came from stardust and we returned to
it
for the study of astrophysics or
astrobiology
is just that a wonderful complex story
with depth and drama
just the kind that shakespeare told so
well
i actually get frustrated sometimes with
scientists who tell the public the facts
and leave out
the stories behind
the science bearing people burying
people in jargon
and method
i was an art history minor in college
and i now promote science communication
at nasa helping our scientists and
engineers bring not just the detail but
the why the who cares
how did we get here how does this affect
my life and my place on this planet
and what is our future
science science not only informs us it
inspires us the more we learn the more
we crave knowledge and understanding
and science feeds our innate curiosity
we want to know more we want to know
what those points of light in the night
sky are
when we plan at nasa to send humans to
mars we do so to under answer the
fundamental question
are we alone
did life evolve beyond earth
what is the nature of that light
that life
when we look at the thousands of planets
that we've identified around other stars
we want to know are those planets
not just potentially habitable but are
they inhabited
that's why we need not just stem
we need the humanities we need
shakespeare we need the arts we need
design to understand our world and
beyond
shakespeare knew how to tell the story
of the lives of people on this planet
in science we try to take apart all that
is behind that story piece by piece
to understand how it works where it's
going where we are going
but we need to approach these difficult
challenges using both sides of our brain
using our head and our hearts
great science is about so much more than
analyzing data it's about dreaming big
it's about creativity it's about
inspiration and asking the right
questions it's about perseverance and
courage it's about heroes
it's all the things we appreciate about
shakespeare's works powerful
storytelling that stands the test of
time
as we work to solve the most pressing
questions about our origins and our
destiny we must come back to shakespeare
to share the big story of science with
everyone
thank you
thank you
thank you ellen
[Applause]
even after 400 years shakespeare remains
a go-to commentator about contemporary
affairs
he still writes the headlines even if
the events that are happening aren't yet
history
clarence page has built a career around
his keen insights about local and
national affairs
he was recognized for his work with a
pulitzer prize for commentary
he is a nationally syndicated columnist
and a network television commentator
please join me in welcoming clarence
page
i'm a word man
when we celebrate shakespeare we
celebrate the power of words
we scribes often describe washington as
downright shakespearean
and why not he wrote the script
that's what the fellow who just
introduced me said michael whitmore
he told me that four years ago as we
discussed the speeches in the 2012
presidential race
almost all of our political rhetoric
whitmore told me comes from two books
from the 16th and 17th centuries the
king james bible and shakespeare's plays
like me whitmore was impressed by bill
clinton's speech
his comedic and sometimes ad-lib
speech at the democratic national
convention
bubba is back i said
even president obama sounded like he
thought the former president did a
better job of selling the current
president and the current president did
as obama said somebody emailed me after
his speech and they said you need to
appoint him to be the secretary of
explaining stuff
i like that said obama and i do too
later comedian seth meyers observed on
saturday night live that we already have
a job for that it's called president
and that's true explaining stuff is a
big part of the job some leaders do it
better than others do in fact the use of
a shakespearean simplicity in language
is something that uh president clinton
uh president obama and donald trump hold
in common
yes we cannot get this far to the
program without mentioning the name of
donald trump
in fact at a campaign rallied back in
december in hilton head the republican
frontrunner explained the importance of
words while describing the state
department
quote
i'm telling you
i used to use the word incompetent
now i call them stupid
i went to an ivy league school i'm very
highly educated i know words
i know the best words
but there's no better word than stupid
right
unquote
well no wonder michael whitmore was
intrigued by the language of politics
in fact michael took the text of bill
clinton's remarks compared to obama's
speech and found that clinton relied
almost exclusively on single syllabic
single syllable action-oriented words
words that come from the germanic
anglo-saxon roots of english
obama more often employed larger and
more nuanced latin rooted words
must be that university of chicago
exposure right
words that the french brought to english
with the norman conquest back in 1066.
today whitmore said you could say that
almost all of our political rhetoric
comes from those two books
well indeed
political speech comes to us in two
speeds as michael also said or i would
call them socioeconomic tongues
the uh there was latin and its
derivative uh romance languages french
spanish italian became the english
spoken mainly by elites in the law
bureaucracy and the intelligentsia
short action-oriented anglo-saxon words
with the hard continents fighting eating
hiking became the day-to-day language
that common people talk
want to know the difference listen to
rock and roll
rock and roll rhythms are not very
tolerant of
fancy latinate words
and notable exceptions as michael
pointed out was the rolling stones
classic
i can't get no
satisfaction
go from the go from the latinate to the
angle to the anglo-saxon in a very
effective way but then mick jagger ran
into something of a dilemma what can he
get to rhyme with satisfaction
well we all know the answer don't we
girly action
if you're like me now that song will be
stuck in your head all day won't it
but oh no it's only rock and roll but i
like it
yes i do
old will
fits remarkably well even in our age of
rock and roll and raucous discourse
all the world's a stage he said and all
the men and women merely players they
have their exit center entrances and one
man in his time plays many parts
indeed this is true
i have found that
in fact i wonder what would shakespeare
say about today's era of government
shutdowns debt ceiling showdowns and
obamacare website meltdowns he wouldn't
be surprised
as walmart said he wrote the script
indeed dealing with kings queens
aristocrats others from the top to the
bottom of society shakespeare understood
our history repeats itself in very
different times and places thus it is
not hard for us to imagine shakespeare
writing the script for today's politics
might have speaker paul ryan refusing
pleas from others to run for president
reminding us of hamlet to be or not to
be that is the question
republican chair reince priebus could
borrow from 12th night to address paul
ryan be not afraid of greatness
some are born great some achieve
greatness some of greatness thrust upon
them
president obama could turn to hamlet
addressing congressional gop leaders do
you think i am easier to be played on
that a pipe
or donald trump to megan kelly
i'll speak daggers to her but use none
we can hope
or from othello
rude am i in my speech but a little
blessed with the soft phase of peace
as you like it provides a good line for
supreme court justice candidate excuse
me merrick garland as he visits senators
on capitol hill
i like this place and will
excuse me i like this place and
willingly could waste my time in it
or ted cruz
the world has grown so bad that rims
make prey where eagles dare not perch
or
my good friend justice clarence thomas
brevity is the soul of wit
or
back to the ever quotable donald trump
though this be madness yet there is a
method in it
well indeed
whatever happens in our politics today
we will be in for more surprises but one
thing that i think will be consistent we
know who wrote the script thank you very
much
thank you sir
thank you clarence
we're going to be thinking about those
rock and roll songs and looking for
those latinate words
for many of us our first encounter with
shakespeare was in high school
our current our next presenter is no
exception
a senior at bell multicultural high
school here in washington dc
francisca piantini is a member of the
folger's lilly mckee high school fellows
program
she is vice president of her school's
book club and she is a member of the
green team
please join me in welcoming francisca
piantini
good afternoon today i'll be speaking to
you about my shakespeare story and also
how i believe that shakespeare is still
relevant to today's teenage
era
and my
shakespeare story began when i was in
ninth grade i had recently arrived from
dominican republic in the caribbean when
i was 11 years old i was a seventh
grader i didn't know any english so i
struggled to
make grades in my classes
in learning and keeping up with my
classmates
i started here in the library i read
books and books and more books
all throughout the years in two years i
learned english and i was proficient in
advance even more advanced than my other
united states students that were born
here
when i became a ninth grader and i went
to bel multicultural high school i
started reading macbeth with the book
club
the language of shakespeare amazed me it
memorized me i was so intrigued by how
the language has changed in so many
years and how people could still read
this and understand it and make ideas
out of it
i decided that i was still gonna
keep reading shakespeare that i was
gonna be a fan of his
so i kept reading my path i came out of
my shell and started speaking to other
students about it we were learning
together we were learning words we were
learning about feelings and what
happened in these stories together
when i became a 10th grader we read
julius caesar we were learning about
friendship everybody was interested in
the story and they didn't even really
know who shakespeare was yet
when i was in 11th grade i applied to
the lily mackey fellowship here at the
folio library and i got accepted in the
fall of my
11th grade year i was excited the
classes began it was a rigorous course
we read as you like it pericles hamlet
and we also read the sonnets we went to
multiple multiple plays here in the fojo
library and it was
amazing to say the least
we met a lot of experts and we learned a
lot about ourselves how shakespeare was
still relevant to today's society
at school meanwhile in my 12th grade ap
english class we were we were reading
othello
then we watched othello in this spring
and we had a workshop well where
statements were posed such as if your
friend told you your girlfriend or
boyfriend was being unloyal to you who
would you believe
this was answered with multiple
opinions from my classmates and they
were using evidence from their own lives
they didn't know it was they were
talking about shakespeare
then when the teacher said well this is
what happened in othello he decided to
trust his friend instead of his lover
shakespeare is still relevant today
because he talks about what makes us
humans our feelings our relationships to
others who we choose to believe who
choose not to trust
who we rely on who we grieve
shakespeare would still remain relevant
in four more hundred years because he
speaks about humanity and his stories
will always be relevant thank you
that's our lily mckee fellow francisca
piantini
great job
well and you started the next discussion
what does it mean to be human
this question drove our next presenter
just to dedicate his life to a lifelong
study of the humanities
as a combat infantry advisor at the age
of 20 he came face to face with a host
of cruci critical questions that poets
and writers and philosophers have been
struggling with for generations
william adams better known as bro adams
spent his career fostering a love of
learning and exploration of our humanity
he served as the president of bucknell
university and the president of colby
college he is now the chairman of the
national endowment for the humanities
please join me in welcoming bro adams
thank you
this is a story about what i would call
the sociological
and existential significance
of king lear
in the 1980s i was teaching at stanford
university in what was then called the
great works in western culture program
this was a program that every student at
stanford
had to pass through in the first year in
order to get on
with the baccalaureate degree
and in the course of reading the great
works of western culture as you can
imagine we read shakespeare
and for a number of years the play that
we read was king lear
amazing remarkable extraordinary play
which was a pleasure to teach and as i
taught it
i was dealing of course with students
between the ages of 18 and 22 but most
of them were about 18.
teaching the play to students who are 18
years old
went rather naturally to the place where
they knew or the places they knew and
that had to do with the way this play is
about a family and i would say a deeply
dysfunctional family
in particular and most of the
conversations in most of the work and
most of the significance of the play for
them arose from those relationships that
lear has with his daughters particularly
and all of the other interestingly
domestic relationships that occur during
the play at the end of my time at
stanford ironically i was invited to
participate in a seminar found funded by
the national endowment for the
humanities
teaching shakespeare in a summer program
to professionals and particularly people
from not-for-profit organizations
including
a number of executives chief executives
of very important foundations in
california and beyond and it was so
interesting the difference in the way
these people read the play i learned
from them that what was in the
foreground of this play for them was not
the domestic and the familial which i
was very accustomed to talking about
what was in the foreground for them was
the organizations
lear not as a family member but as the
ceo of an organization and someone whose
personality and character is formed over
time around his organizational role his
being the king of this kingdom
even though that's a kind of background
consideration in much of the play
and it was fascinating to follow them
through this play and understand that
one of the really profound dimensions of
this drama
is the way in which this person cannot
get over the fact
that for most of the day
he spends his time giving people orders
and telling people what to do and of
course when he comes back into that
domestic context he's at a complete loss
as to how to be how to live with others
and of course the drama the play figures
centrally around his abandonment
of that role
and his abandonment of that persona but
of course he can't abandon it so as he
dis
lodges himself from that
context
he finds himself nowhere the fool says
to him principally in that one of those
first scenes
i am a fool you are nothing and he goes
off onto this parade around to his
daughter's residences of course and at
every turn he's rebuffed
goneril waits for him at albany's palace
treats his people badly puts the fools
in the stock and lear
is no longer able to understand the
world or cope with the world
so this is a play in very many ways
about what happens to people
in great positions of authority when
they enter other
modes and domains of life
and how difficult it is
to lose that sense of self and sense of
being that's given to us by positions of
authority
i thought this was a very interesting
reading of the play and it helped me
understand
what shakespeare was doing with lear but
i didn't really understand it until
years later
when i myself had the opportunity to
take on positions of significant
responsibility in the presidency of two
colleges
and for me
one of the most difficult
aspects of that work
was coming home
at night
after having been in the office all day
walking in the front door and sitting
down at a dinner table with my wife and
two young children
there's that wonderful
moment when lear is with
his his
entourage at
albany's palace and oswald the ballot to
goneril comes up to him and says
something insulting and he says do you
know who i am
and he says oswald said yes
you are my lady's father
and he goes into a rage a rage which
gets repeated numerous times
as he feels himself divested
of the meaning of the world that had
been his in this context of
the kingship
so there i was at the dinner table with
my two children wanting to say do you
know who i am
and of course that doesn't work at the
dinner table
and it was it was just so illuminating
to me
to understand how shakespeare
illuminates us
and gives us perspective on our lives
through these wonderful plays
that show us who we are in so many
powerful ways thank you very much
thank you
thank you bro
kyah henderson has served as chancellor
of the d.c public school system since
2010
under her leadership dcps has become the
fastest improving urban school district
in the country
she accomplished this through an intense
focus on improving teacher quality and
actively engaging students and families
she has focused on creating programs
that benefit all students please join me
in welcoming kya henderson
great to have you here
like most high school students i had a
pretty casual relationship with
shakespeare growing up
i tolerated plays like romeo and juliet
hamlet and a midsummer night's dream
i plotted through sonnets vaguely
understanding i am big pentameter
but then we read othello
and i fell in love
the murder the intrigue the horrible
scoundrel iago the gorgeous desdemona
the loyal casio
it was the best of great storytelling
and great theater
but even more than that it was the first
time that i had encountered a main
character who was a person of color
in such a significant historical work
i was surprised
but more importantly i was affirmed
the play showed me that people who
looked like me
were an important part of the world
story
william shakespeare
helped to validate my place in history
the play challenged me
i was struck by how despised othello was
for the life of me i couldn't understand
what this poor moor had done that
deserved all of this treachery
he seemed to only be guilty of excelling
in a world stacked against people like
him
personally and professionally othello
was the man
he rose through the ranks of a foreign
army
he took the top spot and he got the girl
good stuff
but his unlikely success set the stage
for a string of jealousy fueled murders
but that made me love him even more
because othello
showed this little black girl that even
in a hostile world
people like me could excel
not only could we excel in fact we've
been doing it throughout history for
hundreds of years
and in my current role
i have the pleasure and the honor of
sharing that important lesson
with the fifty thousand students of dc
public schools
so my students and i
we owe a huge debt to the bard
thank you william shakespeare for
showing us who we could be in the
thank
world
thank you kaya
a few months ago we began commemorating
this significant anniversary
we call it the wonder of will and it's
involved a tour of
first folios the 1623 complete works of
shakespeare to 50 states and two
territories
exhibitions performances educational
outreach online events we're so happy
that we're able to do this for this year
and the centerpiece has been us an
initiative to collect shakespeare's
story stories made out of videos and
having them posted under the hashtag
myshakes400
we've already been moved by the stories
that we've heard so far and i wanted to
share a couple of them with you now
including one from joss whedon who you
may know as the director of the avengers
or since you're in this room you
probably also know that he created a
beautiful version of much about nothing
filming it in his home in a weekend so
please let's have a look at some of
these videos that range from selfies on
iphones all the way to shots by
filmmakers
[Applause]
[Music]
share your favorite shakespeare quote oh
god
okay today
it's and yet i wish but for the thing i
have my bounty is as boundless as the
sea my love is deep the more i give to
thee the more i have for both are
infinite
valentine's day much about nothing
the tempest
uh winter's tale i mean they've all
they're all
marvels so i sort of refused to
pick a favorite as i say it's easy to
pick a least favorite
question
there were moments in my life where i
felt like oh i don't belong or i don't
fit in or that doesn't relate to me and
something like shakespeare was so
distant from me i didn't think that was
there was anything for me in shakespeare
with princes and royalty dying what that
doesn't pertain to me that's not my
story but then when i realized again
going back to the human condition that
these people they fall in love they get
jealous they have rage all of those
things i get people ask me a lot what my
favorite line of shakespeare is and i
think they always expect me to wheel out
some big multi-syllable word or some big
classical illusion but i always say oh
she's warm
it's the climax of the winter's tale
it's a moment when a man who believes
he's lost everything suddenly gets it
back again and has a second chance at
his happiness i like shakespeare's
bloody vicious plays which is also why i
love titus andronicus i think my
favorite childhood memory
earliest on was
we did a reading of
henry iv part one
at thanksgiving and it was an
opportunity for me
to make fun of how fat my stepfather was
uh which i did every day but way more
articulately because he was false stuff
and i was how
and i got to go through the whole
manning triox with the pudding in his
belly this bit and um
it was a giddy time
shakespeare is
a phenomenon he
made literature something that people
could discuss and argue about and
decide well i believe this but even
though you may believe that i still feel
that this piece of literature holds
something dear to me something that no
one else can understand because i take
it in a certain way you take it in
another way
[Music]
[Applause]
incredible
if you're feeling inspired i hope that
you will make your own my shakes 400
video you should post it on social media
and share it with the hashtag
myshakes400 you can visit folger.edu to
see some of those videos to download
props and to find ways of making your
own video
dubbed intellectual vaudeville by the
new york times our next guest is a
company of an american theater troupe
that is disguised as a comedy team they
are known for taking huge and important
stories and release reducing them to
silly little skits
please and join me in welcoming
uh reid martin and austin austin tichner
from the reduced shakespeare company
you did it you did it
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
i'm reed martin i'm austin titchener and
we are two thirds of the reduced
shakespeare company yes we are a
theatrical comedy troupe known for
taking long boring topics and making
them into short sharp comedies
that's right and our for our first three
shows the complete works of william
shakespeare bridge the complete history
of america abridged and the bible the
complete word of god abridged
ran in london for almost 10 years at the
criterion theater and now in time for
this anniversary year of 2016 we have
created our 10th stage show william
shakespeare's long lost first play
abridged yes
so here's the premise we were on tour in
england last year and we just finished
performing in the theater in leicester
that's right so we went back to titus
which was fun you should explain what
titus is sorry yes you're right when
we're on tour we we travel in a 12-seat
passenger van we call titus van dronicus
it's awesome um yeah so anyways we went
back to titus which was parked in the
parking lot in leicester and we saw this
hole in the parking lot and down in the
hall there was this pile of bones yep
they looked utterly unimportant yeah but
next to the bones was this bundle of
papers and that bundle of papers turned
out to be the most important literary
discovery of the last 400 years
no not 50 shades of grey no we
discovered william shakespeare's long
lost first play and it's we've had to
cut it down and the textual clue
suggests that it's a hundred hours long
it talks about the 100 hours traffic of
our stage and nobody's gonna sit through
that so we are we have cut it down to
two hours and one of the scenes we cut
uh indicates that shakespeare was an
early influence of the comedy team of
aberdeen costello
oh what a glorious day it is here in the
elizabethan era a perfect day to attend
the theater and with so many playhouses
to choose from the rose the curtain the
theater ah petruchio castello ah friar
rabbit
art thou bound for the theater i verily
i am bound for the rose so thou art not
bound for the theater i my lord tis the
rose for which i'm bound but sir i
remain confused thou sayest thou art not
bound for the theater you remain witness
and death the theater is my destination
i am bound for the rose but not the
theater i'm the theater thou i don't
play the club what strange melody
possesses thee i am going to the rose
theater
[Laughter]
now i see we might have been at cross
purposes i ask if you are going to the
theater bourbon is specifically named
playhouse
i mistook you sir i thought they'll
maintain some foul malevolence towards
the rose oh no sir the rose by any other
name
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah i needs must be off good try
or i shall miss the curtain my lord the
curtain is that way why do you tell me
this i don't know third base thank you
very much
one of the other things we realized is
that shakespeare was very young when he
wrote his first play uh we think he was
around 17 and he was young and foolhardy
he didn't know that making king richard
iii of the house of york such a likable
character
could get him beheaded by his patron
queen elizabeth of the rival house of
tudor um in the shakespeare's long-lost
first play richard iii is a super nice
guy
and he's trying to woo beatrice and it's
not going very well so because he cannot
prove a lover he is determined to prove
a vaudevillian
sign no more ladies sign no more men
were deceivers ever
one foot in sea and one on shore to one
thing constant never
so sign up so and let them go and be you
blithe and bonnie
converting all your songs of woe into
hey i was upset when beatrice said she
didn't love me but i slept like a baby i
cried and went to bed
sign off so let them go and be you blind
and bonnie
converting all your songs of woe into
hey my shrink said i was crazy i said i
wanted a second opinion he said okay
you're a hunchback too
so
converting all your songs or bro into
hey they all laughed when i said i
wanted to be a comedian where they're
not laughing now
converting all your songs of woe into
hate
thank you very much
we've got a matinee here in about an
hour so we need to go i'm reed martin
i'm austin and we are two thirds of the
reduced shakespeare company thank you
very much
thank you nice to meet you we'll see you
guys
later
thank you reed and austin
our next presenter is a terrific
colleague and a shakespeare scholar her
book persecution plague and fire
describes the ways in which live
performances can go wrong
either because of gunpowder or
pyrotechnics or the use of live animals
none of which are allowed in the folger
reading room
please join me in welcoming ellen mackay
[Applause]
when i was a senior in college the
culminating course for theater majors
was acting sixth
shakespeare scene study and its
culminating event which took place every
april was a public performance of
highlights from shakespeare's plays now
since i had been more of a torchbearer
type than a hamlet type over the course
of my acting career i was very happy to
net the part of the princess of france
catherine in the play henry v
specifically in the scene where she asks
her lady in waiting to train her in
speaking english this scene is like a
vermeer painting over the course of
shakespeare's war play it opens a window
and casts a vibrant light on a side of
history that we would not otherwise see
at this point the french have been
decimated at the battle of harfleur and
while the dopant sits around moping
and boasting about his horse catherine
sees the writing on the wall
recognizing that her marriage will be
brokered to steal the negotiated peace
she prepares herself for a reality that
everyone else fails to see coming
now i knew full well i could not get all
of this rich context across so i
concentrated on the thing that i knew i
was cast to do namely speak french and
trippingly on the tongue at least until
the point that catherine encounters two
words foot and gown that are homophones
or sound alikes for french obscenities
this she responds to with comic alarm
senor
but then
she also can't resist the opportunity to
repeat this illicit language
the nails
dharma the um
the bilbo
the nick
so my moment came i performed my part in
the sunset on my shakespearean acting
career
and the next day while i was walking
across campus this very appealing
looking person hailed me from across the
quad and came running up and then spoke
to me very slowly and he said
you are learning to speak english
very well
very well
when will you be journeying back to
france
and so
i paused for a moment right in some
confusion trying to figure out how to
handle this before i decided that
honesty was probably the best policy at
which point i said um well actually i'm
from america
and the look on his face was one of
utter and profound and heart-rending
disappointment and unable to pivot to
the usual social niceties he turned and
slouched away
so
i recognize that this story is a bit of
a cliche many actors have recited these
kinds of encounters with people who have
failed to recognize the difference
between an actor and the character that
they perform but for me it was a
profound illumination of the hold that
shakespeare still has on us
this person a perfectly rational seeming
person by all outward signs
was so reluctant to part company with
catherine that he simply did not see or
would not allow himself to see all the
ways in which i was visibly not a 15th
century princess of france
so as you can imagine i dined out on
this story for quite a while but i've
chosen to share it with you today
because i've come to see the ways in
which this spectator and i are more
alike than different you see i too hated
dropping the part of catherine i loved
housing her inside my psyche and having
her as my constant companion and i now
come to believe that one of the reasons
that i went to graduate school to study
shakespeare was to keep myself in the
company of shakespeare's imaginary
persons for as long as i could
and what is more i've come to think that
that's not so much delusional or wishful
thinking as an expression of
shakespeare's formidable ability to
bring his world forward and lodge it in
us and create these encounters on
shockingly intimate ground let me finish
with one short example
so about a year and ago a year and a
half ago i was at a conference at the
sarban on the hatred of the stage in
renaissance europe just believe me it
was in fact a hated phenomenon and there
was a presentation on denunciations of
the actress in 16th century france
and i was struck by how moralists
repeated again and again the same word
amputeek that catherine uses to describe
the indecencies that are foisted on her
by the english tongue and all of a
sudden i have this whole new revelation
of catherine how in imagining herself
preparing to play the role of a french
queen on the english stage she both
raises and sort of mocks the
anti-theatrical critique that is
watching about in the period
now i have to say this is precisely what
interests me as a scholar the way plays
of shakespeare's period draw our
attention back to the conditions of
their own production and force us to
notice how precepts of the period
concerning the emptiness of show or the
corrupt
corrupting force of the theater as an
agent don't match on to the vibrant
multi-dimensional experience of actually
going and seeing a play but i have to
tell you that this presentation struck
me
not just as burst for my mill or
evidence for my argument but potentially
as a revelation of how that idea lodged
in me for in the first place for if i've
made it my business to try to
take apart limited and reductive visions
of the stage perhaps the reason
is that catherine was with me during
those sessions of sweet silent thought
when i was
percolating my research perhaps if i can
now see the way in which she quotes back
the language of theater's detractors
it's because i played her and she primed
me to think that way so i guess my
shakespeare moment is less a moment than
the long arc of my recognition that no
other author is as capable of
orchestrating sustained and sustaining
relations between his characters and
ourselves
[Applause]
thank you ellen
[Applause]
considered by many to be the most
prominent latino playwright in america
octavio solis has written over 20 plays
that have been mounted in major theaters
across the country he's an award-winning
writer and director whose style defies
formula please join me in welcoming
octavio
[Applause]
knows the way it goes she knows the way
it goes son yanked out by the roots at
dawn
la noche buried in the ground like an
old bone that's how long we got that's
how long it takes to live barely time
enough to love casino
la romie knows the way it goes maskinada
you come you kiss and die that's the
cuento only story we got time to tell
cause there it goes there goes my son
he's leaving his romy and she's ready to
die she's taken all day to die and there
it goes up toward the blue above us the
sun over romy and these two babosos in
the parking lot of the hidden valley
shopping center who don't feel the fire
that romy feels but romy knows before
she knows see moan she knows the way and
she's about ready to take it
thus opens my play elotro a work
informed by the tropes and rhythms of a
poet who never came to my hometown of el
paso a writer who didn't know what a
mexican was but somehow managed to leave
him and the entire world a legacy of the
most beautiful words ever strung
together
growing up on the border in texas i
spoke only spanish the household tongue
of my parents and brothers and sisters
but as soon as i went to school i
quickly learned another language
i learned english quickly and with such
eagerness it felt like there was room in
my mouth for all the words in the world
as i got older another teacher
television
taught me even more words through the
dizzying array of idioms found in
cartoons variety shows comedies westerns
and cop dramas
and still
there was the home language of the
street and our kitchen to remind us of
who we were and where we came from
but in my second year of high school a
stupendous thing happened
i got cast in a production of a
midsummer night's dream
and suddenly i knew there was yet a
third language to learn
a language of metaphor
and before i learned how to pronounce
the word shakespeare
i was writing the waves of lyricism and
rhyme and alliteration i was confounded
by the double and triple meanings and
words but the music of the verse the
elegant turns the phrase and brash
colloquialisms
and as i took on the role of bottom
the comic lexicon of nonsense bodiness
and magic streamed out of my new
fashioned mouth and made not an ass of
me
but an artist
because this is the moment i knew i
wanted to write like this man
because this man had made a metaphor
that expressed my world
i wanted to create my own language for
my own works but that took more time
than i thought
i played iago in my senior year in
college and still all i could do was
marvel at how sense and sensibility were
so beautifully fused so that what was
expressed on stage was not thought or
feeling but some wondrous human marriage
of the two
inseparable
and complete
how will could endow a vile man with
such heavenly language
and then grace the mouths of peasants
and soldiers with uncommon poetry
these were mysteries that this mexican
kid just couldn't work out
but shakespeare shakespeare taught me
how
he taught me
humanist universe everyone has a soul of
a poet
a king can be crude and a drudge speak
with angels
but he also taught me that as his king
and drudge spoke to our world
our kings and drudges must speak to his
so i turn to the language that course
through my childhood the language where
spanish and english views to make
spanglish the natural poetry the dance
trippingly and the lengua the rhythms of
my street where rancheritas come with a
spanish drawl and everyone speaks with a
spanish accident
i found my way into the city and would
rather let the idiom find its way into
me
and thereby hangs a cuento
because once again my mouth was big
enough for more words more ideas more
metaphors than i ever thought possible
in my play elotro a young girl stands
between two fathers she must choose
between and laments in her head the
brevity of life it's hard slogs and
sweet joys experienced in the single arc
of the sun because she wants to die
the metaphor is hers to make
but she is a metaphor too
for a mexican kid in el paso texas who
learned an extraordinary
language wrought by genius 400 years and
more ago
[Applause]
thank you
donna denise is the chair of the english
department at saint albans school for
boys here in washington d.c
she's contributed to a teaching resource
called shakespeare set free which is and
she's author of the poetry chap book the
lover's voice as well as a book of poems
broken like job
she was a member of the teaching
shakespeare institute here at the folger
in 1984 and has been contributing to the
student work that has been happening
here as they excel in their work at the
folger please join me in welcoming donna
denise
so
my first experience with shakespeare was
one in which i happened i was about 13
and i
happened to watch a tv show and it was
with japanese characters and it was
english subtitles i came to find out
later
after a totally absorbing experience
that it was kurosawa's throne of blood
and i think it was so satisfying for me
because as an african-american
i felt like there was so much when i was
growing up that seemed unjust and here
was divine justice and boy was it
satisfying
but my next deep experience with
shakespeare occurred at the end of
graduate school
i had been raised by maternal
grandparents
and my father's is haitian well educated
for him education was
the the top
when i was about to graduate he wanted
to see me march
however there had been a procedural
glitch in the final days before the
ceremony and i learned i was going to
have to wait
another semester in order to actually
graduate
he was furious
he blamed me
he said once again you get things wrong
do you ever get things right even though
it wasn't my fault
and so as i drove him back to the
airport he came from new york he thought
the trip had been a waste
as i drove him back to the airport he's
yelling at me i'm yelling at him what
have you ever done what have you ever
helped us you'd let my mother down you
let my father go you've let me down i
mean it was one of those family rows
that
i think
we all can recognize he's yelling in
french
in creole i'm yelling in english
i dropped him at the airport immediately
went to my professor's house she was
working in her garden
pulling up
tomatoes pulling out tomatoes pulling up
lettuce and things and i went into a
rail against my father
she listened
carefully and she stopped and said your
father gave you everything you need he
gave you life
he gave you good brains
and he gave you good looks that stopped
me for a minute
everything else you can get on your own
and
it wasn't good enough
i still criticized him and finally she
turned to me and she said
the branch that attacks the tree will
itself die
what
speak english
she says the branch that attacks the
tree will itself die the merchant of
venice read it think about it
so i immediately
thought stopped in my tracks the
merchant of venice she said this is the
play where shakespeare was prophet and
so began our discussion
in a world
that comes to confuse the material with
the spiritual every human relationship
is tainted
so a father sets his daughter up as a
lottery prize
friends base their relations on
borrowing and lending money
christians engaged in a slave trade
condemn a jew
for desiring a pound of flesh
and porsha
dear porsche
states her racial bigotry against the
prince of morocco and later gives a
speech about the quality of mercy
when she has none and neither do the
others for [ __ ]
so when all human flesh has a price a
material worth anything is possible
for a minute boy did that stop me in my
tracks
i began to understand my father's need
to see me walk as a confusion
a confusion of spiritual with material i
was going to get my degree
but he needed to see me walk
and i was guilty too
so
at that point i began to see the
relevance of shakespeare in my life
and that's the relevance that i love to
bring to my classroom for students today
certainly experience the same lesson of
confused values
for example they apply to college lots
of seniors
but it's really not about just getting
an education soon as they say they're
into college it's which college
okay
or someone gets engaged
and they say oh they found the love of
my life
i have a ring
and we want to see the ring we want to
see the size of the ring
or
how about this
at graduation
when everyone's happy and celebrating
the the
the movement through education
and now we're going to go off
kids go up to each other and they say
what'd you get what'd you get for
graduation
what would happen i say to students if
you turned and you said to your friend i
got a lot of love
and a lot of support from my parents
he got nothing huh
so that's what i think we live in a
world in which this play the merchant of
venice
is so apropos to our time
and it is a play that teaches us a lot
about the confusion of spiritual and
material on religious grounds
on
mercantile grounds and on human grounds
and for me
i thank my teacher
because she taught me more than the
merchant of venice and thank you
shakespeare
[Applause]
thank you donna
our next presenter has served as a
justice department lawyer as assistant
watergate special prosecutor chief
counsel to the senate judiciary
committee and taught law for many years
as a professor at the harvard law school
and at the kennedy school of government
however you're probably more familiar
with him in his current capacity as
associate justice of the united states
supreme court
justice stephen breyer has written many
books and articles including active
liberty
making our democracy work a judge's view
and the court and the world please join
me in welcoming justice stephen breyer
thank you
thank you thank you
thank you
thank you for inviting me here i mean
i've learned so much already it never
stops it never what was that the branch
that turns on the tree will soon die i'm
going to tell that to my children i
think
and and francisco pantini that you said
exactly what i think it never stops
kiddridge said that i think about
shakespeare he said he knows every
person
every kind of person
and if they're what they think how they
feel
how they express themselves
and he takes all those characteristics
and shows you their thinking and their
feelings and their thoughts and their
actions better than they could do
themselves and he does it all in poetry
that's what you said and i take it in
and well i often get asked usually by
lawsuit not law students undergraduates
that's fun for me i get to talk to
undergraduates and they want to be
lawyers you know i mean there we are
some have to and and
there we are they want to be lawyers and
they say what should i study as an
undergraduate
they were doing what you were just
saying there you know how i get up on
this ladder here and and i say well you
know you don't have to study something
leading to law
i can't tell you what to study but i'll
tell you one thing you have one life to
leave
one
and you'll know that life
and you'll know your friends
you'll know your family but that's very
very few
and if you go into humanities for those
four short years
if you learn some other languages
if you read a few books
you'll learn about some lives that
aren't your own
but they're out there
every kind of person so i recommend that
and it comes back in spades to help me i
mean just a few weeks ago we've heard
about a fellow i mean it's been playing
and a fellow what is iago
i mean is there really such a person
i mean he is a real serious rat
and could there be a person like that
then i happen to see a movie a classic
french movie on television uh no i saw
it i saw an airplane tonight it was uh
leisen found a parody children of the
gods
fabulous movie
great movie there's a character in it a
real criminal called lassener and la
sinaire is an egomaniac i mean he is a
rotten person but he has very high
opinion of himself
very high
and cares about nobody else
no emotional reaction to anybody else
it's him the greatest in the world and
the only person that he will fight is
the person who insults him and suggests
he's not the greatest person in the
world and at the end of that film he
goes into a turkish bath where there's
an aristocrat who did look down on him
dead and when he goes and sits down
calmly on the shelf
pulls the cord and waits for the police
to come
what has he proved that he's the
greatest person in the world to whom
himself now ask yourself as i ask myself
why at the end of othello
when they say why did you do this this
marvelous man why have you ruined him
and killed him why
no answer
he's proved it
to himself
someone insults him
you've got to prove he's the greatest
person in the world that's one way of
looking at it you see shakespeare told
me there are such people and it helps
explain the play at least to me and if
in fact you see groundhog day which is
one of the great movies of the world
what does it make me think of it makes
me think of rosalind it makes me think
of orlando when she says hey you're
gonna do this until you get it right you
better understand right isn't that right
i mean and my goodness you there are
problems of intelligent women that they
have some special problems to this day
and you want to know what they are go
look at beatrice
go look at beatrice and benedict and
there they are
so all over the place all over the world
you i want to tell the high school
students the college students the law
students with your one life you better
know about a few others and you better
understand what this world is like and
if you have that desire and i surely
hope you do you can do worse than start
with william
you
shakespeare
thank you just
caroline clay is a 25-year veteran of
the stage film and television most
recently she played both hippolyta and
titania in the folger folger's latest
production of a midsummer night's dream
a native washingtonian she is on the
faculty of the duke ellington school of
arts
she is a playwright who is committed to
telling the stories of unsung women and
of color in history please join me in
welcoming caroline clay
[Applause]
good morning and thank you it is beyond
an honor to be here this morning as a
native washingtonian and a proud product
of the dc public school system uh my
childhood was punctuated with field
trips many of which happened right here
in this building at the folger theater
right next door
um it was here that i first saw
african-american actress franchelle
stuart dorne
an amazing artist a graduate of the yale
school of drama and most recently the
chairman of the school of theater at
university of texas austin campus
i saw her play to tonya when i was in
middle school a role that i had the
honor of playing here just this season
today in the presence of my students
from the duke ellington school of the
arts in the presence of our dc schools
chancellor it cannot be understated it
cannot be underestimated the power of
black and brown children seeing
themselves exemplified and celebrated by
theatrical practitioners making manifest
the message
shakespeare
is for everyone
in a time where it's easy for the
phrases
diversity and inclusion
to ring hollow when used for grant speak
artists producers theater administrators
dramaturgs must lean forward into
communities and truly engage embrace the
intersections of race of gender of
radicalism of culture
one of dorne's greatest roles here at
the folger was the complex and colorful
lady macbeth
fran dorn thank you
for allowing me to be a part of that
legacy
he hath almost subbed
why have you left the chamber
was the hope drunk wherein you dressed
yourself
have it slept since and wakes it now to
look so green and pale at what he did so
freely from this time
such i account thy love
are thou are feared to be the same in
thine own act and valor as thou art in
desire
what's thou have that which i was
schemed the ornament of life
and yet be a coward in my own esteem
letting i dare not wait upon i would
like the poor cat in the adage
when you just do it
then you were a man
and to be more than what you were you
would be so much more the man no time no
place to then it here yet you would make
both
they have made themselves and their
fitness now does unmake you
i have given suck
and know
how tender tis to love the babe that
milks me
i would
while it was smiling in my face
have plucked my nipple from its boneless
gums and dashed its brains out had i so
sworn as you have done to this if we
should fail we fail
screw your courage to the sticking place
and will not fail when duncan is asleep
where to the rather of his long day's
journey shall sound they invite him his
two chamberlains will i with wine and
waffles so
convinced
that memory
the water of the brain shall be a fume
and the receipt of reason alembic only
when in swinish sleep their drenched
natures lie as in a death what cannot
you and i perform upon the unguarded
duncan
and what not put upon his spongy offices
who shall bear the guilt
of our great quell
thank you
wow
thank you caroline
thank you
i'd like to thank again all of our
presenters
thank you
thanks to them and thanks to our
generous supporters book tv and c-span 2
the national endowment for the
humanities the national endowment for
the arts the british council google.org
vinton and sigrid surf
metropolitan group apple and all of our
co-hosts across the country thank you
for celebrating 400 years of shakespeare
and now now it's your turn the
celebration isn't complete until your
story has been told
so please visit folger.edu
download a tutor rose or a hamlet dagger
grab a friend grab your iphone
and tell your shakespeare story upload
it to social media under the hashtag
myshakes400 you will be in terrific
company
shakespeare gave us the stories and the
poetry that let us explore who we are
and more importantly
who we might someday become
as we look out onto the horizon of the
21st century
we see what earl lewis has called
our yet to be perfected future
on this 400th anniversary of
shakespeare's death
we celebrate shakespeare's staying power
as a poet as a playwright and as a
cultural force
but we also celebrate the infinite
adaptability of his works and the fact
that they sustain a conversation with a
truly diverse set of languages and
cultural forms
that conversation continues because of
what we every one of us
bring to it
shakespeare belongs to all of us
a traveler without a passport
he stands at the edge of a vast world of
imagination of history and of the
mystery of the human heart
we should continue to explore all three
thank you
[Applause]
let's give another round of applause to
our amazing presenters
thank you
thank you
[Music]
you know we're a building that is filled
with rare books and manuscripts and the
record of today will probably be on a
digital medium that will need to survive
for a century we'll have to figure out
how to do that but i hope that in 2116
when folks are again in this room and
thinking about what we said then that
they'll look at today and say that was a
fellowship in a congregation of people
who were truly part of an enduring and
powerful legacy that we can celebrate
again and again
in just a few moments we're going to be
opening up the phones for a national
shakespeare call in discussion here with
book tv's peter slan
thank you for joining us at the folger
shakespeare library for the wonder of
will and learn more about how you can
participate in the 400th at
folger.edu please join me in welcoming
petersland
[Applause]
and as michael whitmore just said it is
now your turn we want to hear from you
you've heard from this audience for an
hour and a half
and it's your turn 202 is the area code
748 8200 if you live in the east and
central time zone 748 8201 if you live
in the mountain and pacific time zones
and those of you here in the audience if
you have any questions we have some
audience mics set up as well and we'll
be taking those questions michael
whitmore the director of the folger
shakespeare library and ellen mackay
of
indiana university will be joining us up
here to answer all your questions
now michael whitmore we've spent
we've spent the last hour and a half
hearing nice things about william
shakespeare what's the uh
what's are you going to ask me a hard
question what's the criticism you can go
right over there if you want what's the
criticism what's the criticism of why
he's no good yeah is there a criticism
well he used a lot of really long words
and he had a hard time stopping himself
when he saw a metaphor or an image that
he loved he just he was like a greyhound
going after a rabbit he just had to go
so even people who knew shakespeare said
would that he had blotted a few of those
words
uh he really couldn't resist it's like
cleopatra's nose once he saw it he
couldn't resist but they say that about
his metaphors and his analogy so you
know if you have to pick one that would
probably be it ellen mackay for those of
us who have tried and tried and tried to
access
william shakespeare what's your advice
i guess my advice is
there are many ways happily of coming at
shakespeare you're not alone if you find
that there's a maybe a high hurdle there
and performances and remediations of
shakespeare shakespeare and music
shakespeare and comic books
shakespeare in memes
um is a perfectly suitable and entirely
fabulous way of gaining access to him
there's no reason that shakespeare has
to be tied to high culture or
you know arcane practices of
interpretation
when we think about what it must have
felt like to see medieval history
presented to people in england you know
it's 200 year old history that they were
seeing in london they were hearing it in
this verse form called iambic pentameter
and this new genre called professional
theater
that's probably
think about what's happening now in new
york and broadway when americans are
seeing
their colonial history presented in a
new art form in an idiom of hip-hop and
being reintroduced to their history it's
such a great example of you know how
contemporary forms can teach us what it
must have been like then and why that
tradition of storytelling with new
adaptations or new language just keeps
going
well let's hear from our viewers and
let's begin with a call from jim in king
george virginia
jim you're on book tv at the folger
library
thank you i appreciate the program and i
appreciate the attempt to universalize
but i'm afraid there was too much
identity politics in the presentations
given this afternoon
and not enough
on the universal quality
i think the supreme court justice
buyer
said it best when he talked about the
universal quality
of a fellow
and some of the other characters
in the play and less about
what were identity politics
so
please
emphasize
universal qualities
and less on
the particular identities
of the
presenters
and the characters that were described
jim michael whitmore well i think jim
your point is that these plays speak to
everybody and when we take the plays up
and make them their own our own we bring
our own perspective to it and i i
appreciate what you're saying because i
do think shakespeare is a universal
writer and when we encounter his stories
we feel like shakespeare's describing us
and so the fact that so many people have
brought their own lives and yeah their
own particular perspective to
shakespeare shows us just what a
universal writer he really is
and so you know i hope everyone is
watching the show today leaves feeling
that shakespeare can speak to them can
speak for them but that also they can
speak shakespeare's words in the way
that they want let's take another call
this is another gym in maslin ohio jim
go ahead
oh good afternoon
mr whitmore i also very much enjoyed the
tour of the folger library that you did
with peter slinn a while back
i'm 38 years a teacher of science and
math but
as an undergrad i was one of those rare
students who took the studied humanities
along with the science sciences and i
had three terms of shakespeare
simultaneously with three of physics
and which is going to get to my question
in a second in 1984 i got to visit
stratford upon avon
i picked up a couple of books there that
i'll commend quickly every man's
companion to shakespeare a british
publication by dent gareth and barbara
lloyd evans and a complete dictionary of
shakespeare quotations another dent
publication by d.c browning
great to add to the folger volumes that
you publish
on someone's shelf
my question
with the emphasis on modern technologies
and health sciences and other stem
focused curricula in our education
systems at all levels do you think
enough students will continue to study
shakespeare uh to maintain some
familiarity and that it may be uh still
offered as dedicated courses at the
college level as opposed to just kind of
inserting shakespeare in a survey course
thank you well let's direct that to our
shakespeare scholar and teacher ellen
mackay of indiana university sure
well i have great hope for the endurance
of shakespeare he's made it this far
it's pretty impressive um i have great
hopes he'll continue at least another
400 years the rationale
or the proof behind those hopes i guess
is that uh in many curricula where
there's been an openness a larger
freedom to include texts that uh speak
to
a variety of populations and come from a
variety of places of origin
in the midst of those curricular
revisions shakespeare still enrolls we
can offer as many shakespeare sections
as we would like in my department
and they fill
and so many of us see the teaching of
shakespeare as an opportunity really to
quicken the appetite for humanity's
oriented thinking of all shapes and
forms um shakespeare really if he
encompasses all if he feels to us that
he speaks to everything um surely that's
an advantage we can draw out really to
make the case for the humanities and for
the necessity of its continuance well
one of the things that the folger
library did here was uh asked high
school students to send in tweets happy
birthday tweets
to william shakespeare and forrest in
edgewood
high school in wisconsin says thou saucy
boil brain
canker blossom
let's take another call and this is jane
in weatherford texas hi jane
hello
thank you again to sue stan and for this
wonderful program
um i attended college for the first time
in my life to age 65
and though i had a familiarity with the
plays of romeo and juliet macbeth
so on it wasn't until i
enrolled in theater that i was really
able to understand
the words of shakespeare
and i performed in some of the plays
even at that age
and
after one of my performances my younger
brother
gave me a copy of
works of shakespeare which included
solids folios
and plays
and sad to say
during katrina i lost that book
and i still feel that loss every day
thank you
oh that's a tough one
we run
a research library with one of the
largest collections of english books in
the world and even european books
and we have a lot of books from this
period but there are so many that are
lost
and it reminds me of when prospero says
at the end of the tempest i'm going to
drown my book
for those of us who love books and wish
that we had more plays by shakespeare we
know that he wrote at least two that
they exist but we don't have them
that feeling that you could actually
lose a book
and once it's gone it's gone
is so heartbreaking
uh i think what you're feeling about
your own book is the way we feel about
books in the past and that's why
libraries are so important because we
need to save these stories and we need
to have other people reading them in the
long run
seraphine great falls high michigan
happy birthday shakespeare thank you for
inspiring many great authors and actors
around the world especially in small
towns
what does she mean by that ellen mackay
well shakespeare is one of the truly
challenging playwrights who is routinely
produced in small theater companies so
um you know the kind of uh everyday
small town fair that might be kind of
neil simon plays is often enhanced with
plays that would i think normally be
considered really difficult right
they're challenging for the most
incredibly dynamic talented thespians we
have
and so there's something fabulous about
the fact that um those of us who are
english language speakers often
although not exclusively right but for
many of us our theatrical tradition
really requires that we include
shakespeare in the repertoire and we
push ourselves to create meaning out of
works that um you know at their most
complex i think are incredibly
challenging and incredibly rewarding i
think the last speaker really gave voice
to the satisfactions of that process and
michael whitmore i think it was the
young lady in high school who said uh
during the program that shakespeare is
accessible today because he speaks to us
today
i think his voice is one we remember
you know the language is 400 years old
so there are some of those words that we
no longer remember
but even if you only understand 20 of
those words
that 20
is
fantastic
and the story that they wrap around that
they tell is one that you can understand
and enjoy whether you're in boise or in
miami or in boston or in tempe
it's the stories that get us into all of
that beautiful language so i i think the
stories are on his side and that's how
we get a leg up when it comes to those
really demanding
passages and words
and if anyone here in the folger reading
room would like to ask a question we
have a mic right in the front
ben's in telluride colorado ben go ahead
hi uh thank you for taking my call and
i'm
really enjoying your show
such a delight to see it on his birthday
and the date of his passing too
the reason i'm calling is i feel very
strongly about
the value of what you're doing here
presenting
shakespeare to his mass of an audience
as you can in a in a way that makes him
seem as accessible as he can be
and i'm wondering why we don't have a
24-hour
station television station alas
it does only jake
and gives us
all the various ways it takes for it's
been studied and presented performed and
and so on and so forth and applied in so
many different ways
and i think you're talking about c-span
three yeah
our american history yeah this is a this
is unusual for us
uh because
we do non-fiction on book tv and so this
is kind of a special occasion for us but
ellen makai
how accessible is william shakespeare's
work today and where would you recommend
ben and telluride colorado go
well i'd start with youtube if you're
looking for filmic performances
because if you're interested in the
range of approaches the kind of global
range of approaches but also this range
from the highly professional to the
highly amateur
youtube is a fantastic place to see
shakespeare performed and i would also
say your local library gives you an
incredible array
of versions of shakespeare that can be
approached by four-year-olds
and that can be approached by those of
us who have been lifelong enthusiasts
i'll put in a plug for live theater
it is a living embodied art form and
it's theater was the first immersive
dynamic art form we have
it's really something to be part of
and so there are so many ways to do it
uh but the point is to do it and i think
if we need to come up with a special
playlist on youtube that curates every
hour 24 hours a day that is a doable
thing but i'm glad to hear that you want
to see more we have a gentleman here at
the mic
good morning
hi ellen and hi michael
i'm from the still vexed bermudez
so it'll be no surprise to know that the
tempest is my favorite shakespeare play
being born in bermuda
i just have a question
was prospero
shakespeare
um
that's a great question and of course
the play is often read as uh
shakespeare's sort of al gore felt
allegorical farewell to his art um and
his uh certainly prosperous relation to
the world making and the use of art and
magic to produce lived environments that
feel realer than real
makes him seem like a perfect stand-in
for the playwright whom we recognize
as having this distinct power of making
us believe so strongly in his characters
and in his worlds um it's a fable that
the tempest is the last play that
shakespeare wrote uh and so there's a
tendency i think to read maybe too far
uh in the autobiographical but at the
same time i kind of love that tendency
because it demonstrates how strongly we
are invested in thinking through how
shakespeare himself thought about his
own profession of his art
anything to add to that mr working i i
think that's exactly right and uh
it is tough to think about him saying
goodbye to the stage but i he must have
said goodbye every time he finished a
play
and if he stood up and was the actor for
hamlet's father playing hamlet's ghost
you can just imagine as he's writing for
his actors and he does write for
specific actors in his company that all
the time shakespeare is thinking of this
character as himself as someone else he
must have been really really good at
pretending that he wasn't who he was
eddie el dorado high school in texas
happy birthday i love you more than
hamlet's mother loves his uncle
malcolm's in elk grove california hi
malcolm please go ahead you're on book
tv
malcolm you're with us
do you know what let's go on to robert
in portland oregon
robert
we're listening
very young in high school i went to a
competition of shakespeare and julius
caesar
and
upon stage i lost my voice and i'd
always heard that that happens to people
it was very young it was a real surprise
to me and my
poor teacher who had to
to endure that
um but i became a fan of shakespeare
after that
i loved his writings and uh
i also love
music and i love groups such as the
beatles
so i was just kind of curious what kind
of influence do you find in today's
modern music
how any ties with shakespeare and our
modern music today thank you
wow
great question who wants to start
well i have to say um
in the wake of prince's death
the line um
good night sweet prince
and flights of angels sing me to thy
rest has been floating through my head
it's one of the last lines in hamlet so
i guess that's the influence sort of
going the wrong way
but it speaks maybe to
to the way in which
you know
great
creators of art
seem um somehow always to be enmeshed in
each other probably because they're
great because they're asking questions
that are so profound
um and that um
and that provokes something so deep in
us
um so maybe they traveled in similar
circles in that way yeah it's such a big
question there's a lot of music that
shakespeare himself wrote he certainly
wrote lyrics to songs and so those have
inspired musical performances but i i
was thinking actually of the soundtrack
to baz luhrmann's romeo and juliet
which was such a big part of that film
there was the look there was the actors
but then there was this fantastic
soundtrack
really you know
dynamic and and immersed in the emotions
of that play and
radiohead did exit music for a film
which was the uh the walking out music
which is one of the best songs they
wrote
or i'll tell you another one a an
independent band a indie band called low
is playing a concert for the first folio
in duluth minnesota
they're going to be playing it to some
early shakespeare silent films but you
can see the direct and indirect ways in
which a writer who can create such great
scenes and stories and then these
beautiful phrases
gets picked up by other people who want
to make a big impression and tell a big
story
kelsey valley high school alabama may
you be treasured as america's favorite
playwright have we co-opted
mr shakespeare over here
i think
shakespeare was born in england but
america adopted him and i think returned
him to the world as a global citizen
i think there is something about the
ways in which in an open-hearted way
americans took on this writer took on
his voice
that freed him up to become something
that he never could have been if he
remained on those shores
and to go back to the beatles you know
these two countries have been trading
things
rock and roll left america and went to
the uk and then it came back
with the beatles
but this is what cultures do with each
other they take their art form and say
well let's do this and then it comes
back
and so i think your question is a really
great one i think he is an american
writer in some way but he's also a
trinidadian writer he's a south african
writer he's a writer in in chinese he's
a filipino writer this is the way great
art works it travels
we have a gentleman here at the mic yes
hello good afternoon my name is simon
mcnabb and i'm a proud father of a lily
mckee fellow so first of all i want to
thank you the folger library for that
program
um i wanted to ask you because it's such
a tragedy in many ways that we don't
know more about shakespeare's life
himself in his details and
hard to kind of figure that in and our
tendency to look at his plays and assume
that they're biographical or
autobiographical whereas we don't know
if they are or
probably most likely they weren't but
one issue i'm very interested in because
of the history of that time what was
going on
with the religious conversion um in the
protestant reformation in england
becoming um not catholic and
how i would like to hear your opinions
on the sense of how you think that
religion may have played into
shakespeare who clearly grew up in the
midst of that had catholic relatives was
in protestant london and any knowledge
or insight you have on that question
thank you
go for it yeah that's a
fantastic scholarly topic and um
not to you know say the sort of cliche
thing but the the source of great and
fabulous and protracted debate
um i think uh it's impossible not to see
shakespeare you know doing things like
staging witches
um and not think that he's thinking
about how the religion the shift in
religion and the period
views things like exorcism and demonism
and the materiality of religion in
everyday life i think uh you know great
scholars have written about what it
means to shift to a protestant tradition
that gets rid of a lot of the
intercessory processes a lot of the ways
in which people can make direct and
intimate contact with the divine and so
some scholars have said well the theater
takes up the space of the church at a
moment in which catholicism and all of
its gorgeous and and deeply sort of
personally and culturally had held
traditions um are no longer available um
but people have also said uh you know
look shakespeare uh
makes us feel that way about the theater
because he's a requisite catholic right
because he's secretly catholic and he
can't help but spark that catholic
feeling within his plays i don't think
we'll know the answer to those questions
but aren't they wonderful questions and
isn't it amazing to think um that we
still care about the reformation in part
because shakespeare's such a vivid
presence within it
next call for our two guests ellen
mackay of
indiana university and michael whitmore
director of the folger shakespeare
library here in washington is megan
ananta new york meg you're on book tv
apologize for that let's try gary in
port washington
new york yes
i was going to ask about
shakespeare being catholic
and the times and die for but the
gentleman
asked a question so i want to ask about
the molovian theory of shakespeare's
authorship
and that christopher marley
was the author which i think has no
validity but i would love to have the
scholars on this day debunk the
conspiracy theory of shakespeare
debunk away michael whitmore
well there have been many candidates
since the 19th century have been
selected as the secret author of the
plays
we have no reason to doubt that he was
anyone but the man from stratford the
son of a glover who moved to london
who learned this fabulous craft of being
in the theater who succeeded and then
went back and retired
but
i think the interest in shakespeare and
our fascination with his abilities and
his outsized influence
has led us to ask
how could anyone be capable of creating
that kind of legacy
you know even francis bacon who was so
educated or another candidate who's been
suggested queen elizabeth the first
what level of education would it take
to get you to the point where your
stories are repeated 400 years later
i think it's very very tough to explain
that and so we've always wanted to know
sometimes we've hoped that knowing who
he was would tell us how to read his
plays but i think what we know about
great art is that it defies the basic
experiences of the writer and it reaches
far out beyond that
i would though say as a director of the
largest shakespeare collection
in the world
we don't swear people to allegiance to
one candidate or another
and frankly the search for the other
writer has led to many interesting
discoveries
you can find out interesting things even
if you're searching for the wrong guy
and so we welcome
qualified scholars and people who need
to use this collection because there is
more to learn about this writer
and can i just say um on the marlovian
theory um one handy way of debunking
that one is just to point out that
marlow is one of the few people of the
period about him we know actually a
tremendous lot including the fact that
he died in a barber all in 1594 which
would cut off a huge swath of the
shakespearean canon from unless he
somehow wrote these plays and stored
them in a magic box
therefore his death which seems pretty
unlikely
faromara high school number 223 in the
bronx
i just wanted to say happy birthday that
i really enjoyed twelfth night
and cecilia from lipscomb academy in
tennessee happy birthday shakespeare i
love your work my first play acting is
ophelia and hamlet opened my eyes
williams in green bush michigan william
you're on book tv go ahead
first of all congratulations mr
whittemore on a wonderful celebration of
the
400th death anniversary of william
shakespeare i too have a question
on the identity issue uh personally i
kind of believe shakespeare
was edward de vere the 17th earl of
oxford as you've as you've learned
many famous people including charlie
chaplin
graham greene
sigmund freud mark twain and others
have also raised issues
regarding shakespeare's true identity
and given the fact that bartlett's
quotations for example
has more
quotations
from shakespeare than from the king
james bible
is it
regardless of whom shakespeare
might have been edward de vere francis
bacon
christopher marlow you make the list up
could it possibly
have been the work of one man only and
if it were
another candidate
if we look at the body of his work the
book as ben johnson said rather than the
picture
would would arose by any other name
smell is sweet would a shakespeare by
any other name read william i think we
got the point mr whitmore i i think we
actually know the names of his
collaborators we now believe that he
collaborated on up to 30 percent of his
plays
so thomas middleton george wilkins
fletcher at least three playwrights who
he worked with and uh it was it was a
collaborative art form in the late 16th
and early 17th centuries you said well
who's really good at opening scenes well
let's get fletcher over here because
and so
we're the more we learn about how
theater worked the more we realized that
some parts of these plays that we credit
to shakespeare were co-written
similarly shakespeare may have written
parts of other plays written by for
example anthony mundy's sir thomas more
there is a page which really looks like
it's by shakespeare it may even be in
shakespeare's handwriting but i think
your question is a really good one how
can one person have such reach
the answer partly is that he in addition
to being a fantastically talented person
was part of a collaborative art form in
an urban
environment that was rapidly
getting contact with trade and other
cultures science was coming online so
all of that including printing which
means that his words get to last beyond
the performance come together and that's
what helps us get shakespeare it's a
convergence of circumstances and i would
just add that alongside the fact that he
probably was
a remarkable person
we have somebody here in the audience
hello my name is eva mcnabb i'm the
daughter of the man who was just at the
mic
um so as you said i'm a lily mckee
fellow here at the folger i'm very
pleased and honored to be one um like
father like daughter i was also thinking
about how
we assume that things about shakespeare
are autobiographical or we assume that
perhaps or thinking about if it's really
him
are there other people working with him
and
for fun i want to know if in your
research and study of shakespeare that
assumptions that you've had about
shakespeare have been debunked or that
you found out something about
shakespeare that you wouldn't have
expected to find out no that's a lovely
question that's great um i think um i
actually thought bro adams's
presentation was great on this front in
the sense that um i think i i have a you
know i'll have a standing reading of a
play
and as i age um and feel my mortality
more tightly gripping me um my position
relative to that play and lear is a
fantastic example um will shift right
and i will come to believe that
shakespeare is actually much more
interested in a different character in a
different plot or subplot
than i had heretofore thought
and uh it's one of the joys of being
able to re-encounter his work it's a
great professional privilege and a great
joy of my life
that i get to sort of experience this
myriad of beliefs about him um and one
of the great things about knowing little
about him is that interpretation
literary interpretation is a scaffolding
that we erect around a play with always
the understanding that you know it's
contingent it's variable we'll stack
things on and take things off and try
out new things and that's part of the
beauty of the work in the same way that
performed adaptations are rich and
wonderful maybe they don't bring across
everything that we thought was valuable
in the play but they'll harp on
something that we hadn't seen before
criticism works the same way so it's
highly variable so i would say yes
all the time my conviction about where
shakespeare's heart is in a given play
or given sonnet will shift over time
let's see if you can source
this uh quote by jess at ames high
school
even though some might think you're a
luxurious mountain goat you're still my
bro happy birthday
oh that's one of the late places that's
fletcher
[Laughter]
yes
you know the the piece that prince
charles read to elizabeth yesterday
from henry viii was actually a piece
from fletcher
phillip is in richmond california
hi phillip
[Music]
well to answer one of your questions uh
to follow up
one things i discovered one of the
things i discovered is that now that we
can fully search about 60 000 of the
books that were printed between 1473 and
1700
i now know that shakespeare did not
invent 1700 words i think what we will
learn over time is that that number is
going to come way way way way down the
lexicographers at the oxford english
dictionary
went for the first book that they'd read
when they wanted to say who used the
word first but
shakespeare borrowed things all the time
and it's a it's no bad thing to say that
he likes to borrow that's one of the
things that made him a great writer was
he said oh this word here i'll use this
ella makai three words that are
attributed to william shakespeare
oh my gosh
uh
all right let me think
uh
he has a lot of uns
a lot of negations
unhoused yeah unhousehold oh and how
unhouseled from
from hamlet uh-huh
uh i'm trying to think and you know i
know i had some i mean i certainly have
encountered them in the past because
i've
um michael whitmore thought your first
piece of position oh this is like a phd
qualifying i know
like stump the professor so uh the
answers are all downstairs by the way
the
incarnating used as a verb in macbeth
is definitely shakespeare
but it's also been said that he created
words like bedroom
marketing
uh
lonely used in a particular sense i you
know if shakespeare invented the modern
meaning of lonely i my heart breaks i
think that's amazing
the phrase harmonious charmingly which i
just love
um in the tempest um which really is
just a strange syntactical construction
unparalleled in the parts of speech that
he assigns words is to me very
indicative of the kind of inventiveness
that i like best about shakespeare he's
already pulling from language we know
but he's messing with it another tweet
sent to the folger library
from andreas at monsignor pace high
school
happy birthday you swag master of
literature
wards in sacramento california ward we
are listening you are on book tv go
ahead
yeah thank you shakespeare is a very
personal thing for me i i went through
the normal
high school education which was terrible
and about it and turned me off
completely but um
my wife insisted i go with her up to the
oregon shakespeare festival in ashland
oregon uh one year and we started
sitting through uh henry the six part
three which i still found pretty
dreadful until i got
to the end when a character named
gloucester came out
who i absolutely fell in love with
completely i love politics and frankly i
love villainy um in politics
and i finished this thing well i'd like
to see more of that guy
and my wife said well you know there was
a whole play about him
uh and i said well we got to come back
for that next year
and every year since 1982 my family has
had an annual summer visit up to ashland
i got a daughter who lives in washington
dc now i got another daughter
at purdue and every year they the the
one absolute family thing is everybody
flies back in august and we drive up to
ashland uh for a week
uh when i was involved in a case at the
supreme court um we walked up to the
folger the night after the argument to
watch a hilarious uh thing about twelfth
night
um in the last two days i noticed on
facebook i keep posting quotes from
shakespeare that i've randomly collected
including last night his the eulogy from
cymbeline
uh for shakespeare's death which i think
is a better eulogy than the one that's
under his gravestone
um
but
anyway uh since you're asking a lot of
trivia questions i had one
that i would put to the panel because
this is one that we debate uh among
those first let me interrupt you before
the quiz starts and say we perform
shakespeare's plays here in the first
elizabethan theater in north america
throughout the year except for the
summer months so when you're thinking
about a road trip you should come to
washington and you should see a first
folio and you should come see
shakespeare performed in this beautiful
tudor
theater
oh i go to the full and when i'm in dc i
go to the folger every visit and i
highly recommend it every visit i walk
through the folger
and i try to see a show if it's there i
just particularly remember seeing the
12th night because we were exhausted
from a supreme court argument and that
was our great uh way of kind of getting
over that exhaustion but let me ask you
this who has two things which play is
most performed richard iii or hamlet
i've heard different theories and who
has more lines hamlet or richard iii
well hamlet has more lines he has the
largest number of lines helmet has the
most lines in a single play but i think
it's actually mad margaret who has the
last the most lines over full sequence
supplies yeah she's in four plays right
and falstaff does he's in multiple plays
i would bet for the most performed that
it's richard iii
hamlet is a long play it's a demanding
play you need a fabulous actor to play
that role and handle all those lines but
uh i know that the internet will answer
this question for us
maybe not correctly
ellen mackay what's your advice to high
school teachers who teach shakespeare
well first of all i respect high school
teachers who teach shakespeare a
tremendous amount
um and i want to send out all my kudos
and all my praise and all my affection
to them because once they come to me
they're already interested they're
already oriented to shakespeare and it's
because of the great work that teachers
are doing across this country i would
say um you know my advice to high school
teachers is as much as it's possible and
not every school board a lot is alike in
this in this way
to allow students to come at shakespeare
at any level from any perspective from
any side to pick up any piece of the
play
because those kinds of encounters that
come from
real and grounded curiosity are uh are
really the best way to learn to find a
point of access and i think in the past
we can think of prior ages in which it
was thought best to sort of curate
shakespeare and try to keep some of the
saucy bits out of the children's ears
you know that doesn't work right i mean
i think understanding shakespeare um as
someone who tries to address the full
range of human experience is really
crucial in bringing children and high
school students and middle school
students and
junior high students into
a really robust and
pleasurable experience with the place
lee is a teacher at wild lake high
school in maryland happy birthday
shakespeare
my life in my classroom would not be the
same without you
catherine's in albuquerque hi catherine
oh hello this has been the most
delightful experience i had trepidations
about today
but i will tell you that it is organic
and will would have loved it
and i have discovered an international
national treasure and this michael
whitmore
um which was a delight and i do have a
question
for dr mccain
catherine before you ask that question
why did you have trepidation about today
well i i am a kind of spoiled child of a
certain era where i had professors like
professor makai
so i have been in this desert
there's no pun intended really but i
mean
you just don't have conversations like
this regularly
and the children of today have been um
shortchanged
in
oh certainly their literature
all the fun that whitmore's had with all
the things he's learned he
has this liberal wonderful great mind
and we don't encourage children to have
that kind of mind
we don't have literature at their
disposal
okay can i say high school teachers in
junior high school i'm sorry i just it
is junior high school teachers and high
school teachers who are the gateway to
the arts and the humanities if you
arrived in college and you had a great
professor there's something that
happened before that and we here at the
folger realize that which is why we want
every child who has an experience with
shakespeare before they're 18
to have a fantastic experience with that
writer because those doors are going to
open
and i think that's where you get great
professors like ellen or the people who
are here on the stage
that's the place and so we really love
those teachers all right catherine
please go ahead and ask your question we
apologize
michael
i want to start a little bit of a
thespian group called the whitmore
mackay
thespian
as a celebration well can you think of a
better gift to give the bard
than to have a bunch of thespians and a
little troop
and we live out in a place where we can
develop them because we have no
competition
so i thought a little lesbian group
uh named after particularly okay but my
question was about the bible and the
translations
do you feel that shakespeare was a great
listener
oh yes i mean i think so that that's an
easy one
i think i think absolutely i think what
michael said that uh you know he was
pulling out of the air this convergence
of of cultural phenomena right religious
change scientific revolution the
emergence of uh rapid promulgation of
print
um and of course in this period the
auditory experience is extraordinarily
pronounced if you're walking through the
city of london you're going to be
walking past open-air pulpits where
people are sermonizing to you right and
so your attention is going to be drawn
to words coming from all directions and
all walks of life and i think that's
what we see so richly embedded in the
plays right the range of characters the
range of social positions that they
occupy this perfectly replicates the
life of the capital the life of england
at the time that he just happened to be
alive
hillary valley high high school
alabama shakespeare hit me up on twitter
because it's your birthday and i'm
throwing you a party
hi my name is angus vale and i'm a huge
shakespeare fan um
i'm just uh when i heard about oregon
shakespeare doing a uh the modern the
translations of shakespeare into modern
english
i was
i was kind of torn because i thought
maybe that is good because it gives a
step up or some sort of accessibility to
shakespeare but then i'm also thinking
well maybe that's bad because
um then it doesn't take away the um the
magic
the beauty and you know the mystery of
coming to shakespeare and learning more
about it
as you come back to it throughout your
life
so i just wanted to know what your
opinion was or do you have to be
politically agnostic about it but i'm
i'm yeah i'm just wondering what you
think about it
well i i think if if it turns out to be
great art and people love it that's
fantastic
i i think shakespeare is a writer who
launched a thousand ships
and if this is a thousand and one that's
terrific
um
but i also think that we don't have to
we probably don't have to defend
shakespeare as a great writer
because he is so successful
uh
even if you go to see these plays and
you see something new because now you
you grasp some part of the plot that you
never got before it's going to be hard
to keep you away from the original
and so i always go with the with the
fact that we keep coming back to this
writer
and we would certainly want to collect
the scripts from this initiative at
oregon because we're the library of
record for shakespeare and we want to
know about that whole legacy but i think
we don't have to um
handicap shakespeare at all i think
he'll do just fine
final word ellen mackay yeah
well i was just thinking in response to
that question
i was born in england but spent most of
my youth in canada um shakespeare is a
bilingual national poet um he's of
course a multilingual national poet and
i think um
his poetry his language is phenomenal
and it sticks with us and those of us
who are lucky enough to be born into
english-speaking languages or in the
english born into english have this
great privilege of accessing him
in his um in his language of origin but
i think also there's something
fantastically gorgeous and wonderful
about encountering him in translation
too
and so i really feel that um there
should be no handcuffs right on the
approach to shakespeare that you want to
take as michael says
he's doing just fine he'll be all right
his plays are still around we can still
find the language with no difficulty um
and so i kind of feel you know bring it
on and unfortunately our time is up
bella in mauston high school wisconsin
happy birthday will thanks for making me
use my brain
and emily in west lafayette high school
indiana what fools such mortals be that
do not celebrate thee
thank you all we want to thank the
folger shakespeare
library
here in washington dc for their help
in setting this call in up and
everything
that we have aired today will re-air
tonight at midnight eastern time that's
9 p.m out the west coast thanks book tv
now continues thank you
thank you all for being here today it
was really really fun to have you here
um we're the ones who were here when we
did it
thank you
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
when i tune into it on